I wanted to talk to you today about the
beginnings of the Greek experience as
far as we know it.
Um,
and I should warn you at once that
the further back in history you go,
the less secure is your knowledge,
especially as a,
I will be doing it at the beginning of
our talk today when you are in a truly
prehistoric period that is before the,
uh,
there is any written evidence from the
period in which you are interested.
So what we do,
what,
what we think we know derives
chiefly from archeological evidence,
which is before writing mute evidence
that has to be interpreted and is very
complicated and is far from secure.
Even a question such as date,
which is so critical for historians is
really quite approximate and subject to
controversy, uh, as is just
about every single thing.
I will tell you for the next few days
we'll be even more than usual subject to
controversy about the most
fundamental things. So, uh,
what you'll be hearing are approximations
as best we can make them of what's
going on.
Well,
we begin our story with the emergence
of the Bronze Age in the Aegean Sea area
that appears to have
taken place about 3000 BC.
I think these days they date it down
about another century to about 2,900.
Precision is impossible.
Don't worry about that. Uh,
and what we find,
the first example of a Bronze Age,
and I used the word civilization now
for the first time because before the
bronze age, there is nothing that
we would define as civilization.
Civilization involves the establishment
of permanent dwelling areas that we call
cities. Uh, as opposed to villages.
Agricultural villages will have existed
all over the place in the late stone age
in the Neolithic period is as it is
known. But there is a difference. Uh,
and a critical difference is that a city,
it contains a number of people
who do not provide for their own,
uh, support. That is to say
they don't produce food.
They need to acquire
it from somebody else.
They do various things like govern and
our priests and our bureaucrats and our
other, uh, non productive
activities that, uh,
depend upon others to feed them.
That's the most narrow definition
of a cities. Of course,
with cities, we typically find
a whole association, uh, of, uh,
cultural characteristics
we deem civilization.
Well,
that's what we see for the first time in
the hygiene area on the island of Crete.
That civilization was
uncovered by the archeologists,
right at the beginning
of the 20th century,
Sir Arthur Evans and Englishman was
responsible for the major work that has
revealed that civilization.
He was captivated by it.
He, uh, I, at one point, he,
I think he convinced himself that he
was a descendant of the kings of that,
uh, civilization. But in
any case, uh, he named it,
he named it after the
legendary King of Crete,
who appears in the Greek mythology
by the name of my nos. Am I Wes? So,
uh, he referred to that civilization
has the, my no one civilization.
And when we use the word my no one,
we mean the,
the civilization whose home is Crete.
It's spread out beyond creek because
the minor ones established what we might
want to call an empire in various
parts of the Mediterranean.
Um, and it's, it's, um, it's,
it's starts with creek.
It is a Bronze Age culture and it is the
first civilization we know in the area
and what we find, uh, in the
minnow and civilization. Chiefly.
I mean, the main place we can, uh,
learn about the civilization from was
the city of [inaudible] sauce located on
the northern shore of Crete
were a great palace complex,
was discovered and is available.
And by the way,
it's an absolutely beautiful site, great
tourist site. You can see quite a lot,
uh, there anyway, that, um,
when you examine that site and draw the
conclusions that are in inevitable from
examining it.
And,
and also I should have said all of
them I know and settlements you, uh,
realize that they look and
seem very much like older,
uh, civilizations that have grown
up in the ancient, Near East.
The real sort of typical home of the
kinds of things we're talking about,
uh, is Mesopotamia,
modern Iraq, the Tigris,
Euphrates valley,
spreading out beyond Iraq and going
up into Syria and neighboring places.
It too was very similar
to the civilization.
Apparently a little bit newer in the Nile
Valley in Egypt about which we know a
great deal more than we know about them.
I know ones because as you know, uh,
in the 19th century,
scholars discovered how
to read the languages that
were written in Egypt and in
Mesopotamia and,
uh,
are able to develop something approaching
history for the period we're talking
about. That is not true
for create because, uh,
although they had a script and we have
available to us tablets with those
writings on them to this day,
no one has deciphered the language
written by the minor ones and therefore we
don't have that kind of knowledge.
So barring that, nonetheless,
what we see reminds us very much
of these ancient bronze age early
civilizations.
Uh,
and so that will be significant as we
talk about how the Greeks different from
that, which gets us to the
Greeks. Excuse me. The,
my ones are not Greeks.
Strictly speaking,
what do we mean when we
say somebody is Greek?
We mean that his native language,
not one that he's acquired subsequently,
but the one that he learned
as a child was Greek.
Some version of the Greek language,
these are linguistic terms,
but of course the people
who spoke to them,
especially in the early years tended
to be part of a relatively narrow
collection of people who
intermarried with each other.
Chief leap and therefore develop
common cultural characteristics.
So of course the language is only a clue
when you, when you speak about Greeks,
you will be speaking about something more
than merely the fact that they spoke a
certain language in the 19th century.
There was a lot of talk about races.
They were people who spoke about the
Greek race or similar races for quite a
long time in the science of
anthropology and subjects like that.
It's been determined that
those terms are inappropriate.
They suggest there's something in the
genes that explain the characteristics of
a particular people. That is certainly
not true. So let's understand each other.
We're talking about a culture when
we're talking about the Greeks,
which is most strikingly a signified
by the language that is spoken.
Well,
the way we can reason things out from
the evidence we have suggests that Greek
speaking peoples came down into
the area around the Aegean Sea,
perhaps around 2000 BC about a thousand
years later than the emergence of the
mine own civilization at Creek.
And again,
I think these days they tend to down
date it by another century or so.
So it might be around 1900 BC.
And we really don't know very much
about these early Greek settlers.
And we begin to know more about,
owes three,
400 years down the road when there appear
buildings and settlements in the world
later inhabited by the Greeks as we
know to which we give the name Mycenaean
now that derives from one site in the
North Eastern Peloponnesus called my Sini
and the name is given because in the
poems of homer and the Iliad and the
Odyssey,
the leading Greek king,
the man who was the leader of the
expedition to Troy is Agamemnon,
who is king of the Argo Lid region
and his Palestine. His home,
uh,
are at my Ct.
And that's why we call the entire culture
bronze age culture running from about
1,602,
perhaps as late as 1100,
but perhaps not so late.
That's what we mean when we speak about
the Mycenaeans, the Mycenaean period.
And please keep it in mind that they
are Greek speakers and we know that with
confidence, something we didn't know
at the beginning of the 20th century
because written evidence is available
on a bunch of clay tablets that were
accidentally baked in some
conflagration in these, uh,
places.
Uh,
same thing is true of a canal sauce in
Crete and perhaps a few other sites in
Crete. Not, not at the same time,
but the reason we have any written
evidence at all is that where we have it,
there was some kind of conflagration that
produced a fire that baked clay into a
pottery.
If in the normal course of events played
as a clay dissolves and disappears and
any message on it as erase it.
In other words,
this was not meant to be a
record to be left for the future.
It was an accident.
These things that we discover,
these writings that we discover
we're meant as practical,
a practical usage in ways that I will
tell you about in a little while.
So anyway, that, uh, writing,
let me back up a step.
When Evans found writing at Kennesaw's,
he found two,
well he actually found seven,
but only two that turned out to
be significant to kinds of script.
I shouldn't even say script. That sounds
like he's writing a nice cursive line.
Two kinds of writing,
um,
one B because he couldn't figure out
what they were. He called one linear,
meaning it's a linear script,
a and linear B because he could tell
by careful analysis that they were,
they were different and he could tell
which pieces belonged to which linear Aa
is earlier and it is associated.
It is clearly the language used by the
my no and kings at Kennesaw state and
other places.
Linear B resembles linear a but
it is clearly different and later.
And one reason we know that we
know and mostly from stratigraphy,
but we can also tell because
it's a much simpler script,
but by no means simple.
These are not alphabets.
These are silly berries.
Every symbol represents a syllable.
In other words,
typically two letters rather than one.
That's a nice step over having every uh,
uh,
having loads and loads and loads of
symbols representing lots of things,
which is true more of linear array
than linear B. But it's still,
we're talking about something
approaching 60 symbols in a silver berry.
And when you think about how hard it is
to learn to read when you're only using
26 symbols and how few
Americans do learn to read,
I keep reading in the paper.
Uh, it's not an easy thing.
It's not a simple matter.
Uh,
imagine what it would be like if you
had to learn about 60 such things. Well,
of course it follows from all of
that is ordinary people did not.
What we learn ultimately from the,
uh, our decipherment of Linear B,
which I've just skipped over,
which was done in the 1950s by a brilliant
young architect who loved solving
problems of this kind and was able to
discover that this was an early form of
Greek and that he could
essentially make out what it said.
At first there was doubt and controversy,
which has completely gone away.
As more and more examples of this
writing had become available.
And scholars are now able by enlarge,
to be confident that they
know what these things say.
So that the fact that this was a
Greek script that was available in the
Mycenaean period tells us very confidently
that the Mycenaeans were Greeks,
but of course a lot was known about
these Mycenaeans well before the, uh,
the syllabary was, um, deciphered.
It's worth saying a word about that
because I want to undermine any great
confidence that you may have and what
you can believe that scholars tell you.
Because we keep finding out how wrong
we are about all kinds of things.
But I would say if you walked into
the leading universities in the world,
that would probably be
German in the 1850s,
and you went to the classics people,
uh, and you said, uh, well, you know,
homer wrote about these places and
my senior and other places, um,
can you tell me where that was?
And they said he was silly fellow.
That's just stories. That's
mythology. That's poetry.
There never was an Agamemnon.
They were never was a, my Sini.
There isn't any such
thing. Uh, and then, uh,
eight in 1870,
a German businessman by the
name of Heinrich Schliemann,
who had not had the benefit
of a university education
and didn't know what a
fool and how ignorant
he was a believe homer.
And he said he wanted to look for Troy.
So we went to where people
thought Troy might be. And uh,
he began digging there.
And before you know what he's discovered,
a mound filled with cities,
which he believed was Troy.
And after the usual amount
of scholarly debate,
that seems to be no doubt that it was,
uh,
the city of Troy.
So having succeeded with that, he
thought, well, now that I've seen Troy,
how about my Sini off he went to the
northeast pill and he says to the site
where he thought it might, it might be
my senior from Homer's account. And, uh,
I wouldn't be telling you this story
and you know, the outcome he founded,
uh,
and it was the excavation
of the site of my Sini,
which was soon followed by the excavation
of other sites from the same period
that made it possible for people to
talk about this culture even before they
could, uh, read the script.
The culture is marked by some
of the following features.
Let's, let's take my Sini,
which is a maybe the best
example of the whole culture.
Certainly it's the, it's, it's a perfect
model for what we're talking about.
What you have to begin with is a town or
a city or a settlement of some kind of
built on top of a hill.
And it's usually intended
to be a formidable hill.
One not easily accessible to anybody
who comes walking along a place.
In other words, that would make
a very nice fort a citadel.
And that's indeed what
we find a at my Sini.
And on that citadel, on that strongly, uh,
rocky fort or,
or citadel vape,
they built what we now
identify as the royal palace,
the Palace of the king.
And,
uh,
that was,
I should point out maybe
about 10 miles from the sea.
Now, not all Mycenaean sites
are so far from the sea.
Some of them are closer.
But what it's important to say is that
none of them are right on the sea.
They're always back, uh, some few miles.
The reason for that I think is that the
early times in which these civilizations
arose,
uh,
saw all kinds of dangers
coming and the most to swift,
this,
the least suspected the one that could
come upon you overnight came from the sea.
People who came by land.
You would be hearing rumblings about it
down the road from villages that were
spread out. But if somebody comes
in from the sea on a ship, uh,
you may find them there in the morning
and you don't know what's what.
So the idea of, for security and safety,
they built their states far from the sea,
but not far.
Because as we shall see,
the Mycenaean civilization was a
commercial one that relied for its wealth,
uh,
upon trade.
And that meant a tr trade
by sea more than by land.
The citadel is typically he
always surrounded by farmland.
And that is of course,
you cannot live in ancient society if
you are not surrounded by farm land
because the,
the food that comes from the soil is
essential for life and you can't count on
trade to provide it to you with any
security later on when times are more
secure, there's trade for grain
as well as for everything else.
But when you're settling a
place in the first place,
you can't rely on somebody
bringing it to you.
You're going to have to have your own
people working in and bringing it up to
you themselves. So the
citadel and the farmland, uh,
surrounding it,
makeup fundamentally the unit,
which is the Mycenaean kingdom.
Well,
the first thing that a
slam on found when he, uh,
Doug at my CV was this
remarkable circle of graves,
which was shafts dug
straight down into the soil.
Uh, and they are referred to to this
day, technically a shaft graves.
And then in other places,
not very far from that main hill,
they found even more remarkable burials,
what we call beehive tombs.
Just imagine a huge beehive in which
let's say the center of the inside of that
might be as much as 50 feet high or more.
And uh,
these were built of extraordinarily huge
heavy stones and very well worked too.
And here's the marvelous thing.
He, the reason he had one cover,
it was that these beehive tombs,
like everything else we're buried.
And this wasn't just the
result of centuries of neglect.
It is clear that they were
built in order to be buried.
That is to say the, uh, the, the,
it was some kind of a big religious
thing going on here where the king,
it was obviously a royal up thing
because the cost of it was so enormous.
Nobody else could afford a tomb of that
kind so that he was a royal tomb closed
forever and yet built at a fantastic
expense in enormous kind of labor.
And the same is true in a general way of
what we find in the royal palace up on
top of the hill at my Sini.
And so what is perfectly clear is the
people who ruled these places were
enormously powerful,
at least locally and wealthy.
Because even if the,
if you imagine that slaves did the work,
you would need a hell of a lot of them
over a long period of time and you had to
feed them, if nothing else. So that
we are talking about a wealthy group.
And of course the other thing
that struck Schliemann, uh,
almost a amazingly was that in the
circle of graves that we've been talking
about, he found all kinds
of precious things buried,
the most striking of which were a death
masks made of pure gold on the remains
of the body,
but also Jules and implements
and weapons of very high expense.
That's what, of course, makes it clear
they were royal in their care by the way.
And there are only a few of these
graves over a large period of time.
So you must imagine these are successive
kings who are being buried in this,
what must have been sacred soil.
So that makes it clear.
We're talking about a wealthy,
a civilization,
at least in which the rulers are wealthy
and in which the rules of course are
very powerful.
Now what we learn both from archeology
and from a references in the linear B
tablets,
is that they engage these cultures,
invade it,
engaged in trade to a significant degree.
You Find Mycenaean elements, tools, other,
other thing,
pottery particularly of a certain kind
of all over the Mediterranean Sea.
You find it in datable, uh, places.
And that's why we can give this
some kind of date, such as in Egypt,
the Mycenaeans had
irregular trade with Egypt.
You find Egyptian things in my
Sini and vice versa. Uh, and also,
uh, presumably, much of it must
have gone into Mesopotamia.
Some of it went all the way
to the western Mediterranean.
This was a civilization that
was not shut in on itself,
but was in touch with the
entire Mediterranean region.
The major thing they seem to be selling,
we're aromatic oils in little vials.
Think of them as well,
some combination of oil and perfume.
I better say something about
oil in the ancient world.
So you get a grip on what's
going on here. Uh, the ancients,
ancient Greeks had no soap.
Think about that for a moment.
That's a problem, isn't, uh,
and yet they wanted to get clean.
And so what the device
they used was to take oil,
typically olive oil,
spread it on themselves,
then get a scraper,
a metal scraper,
and scrape off the oil with it what was
underneath the oil and then finally take
their bath and they would
come and be clean. Um,
now, um, oil is a wonderful thing.
Olive oil is a great thing
in certain forms. You eat it,
the olive itself, you use it
to cook with as oil. You eat.
Some people just put oil on their
salad. I myself can't stand it. But uh,
but it important is it, it has to
take. But that's not all you've,
you'd get oil but crushed
the oil from the, the, uh,
olives that come down from the trees.
Uh,
that's a nasty smell that it has. So if
you're going to use it for this purpose,
it's not going to be good by itself.
You've got to put some nice perfume
onto it in order for it to be usable,
just as your soap would be pretty
horrible without any perfume on it.
So, uh, it looks as though
what the Mycenaeans did.
Greece is filled with
wonderful olive trees,
and so they obviously took the,
uh, the oil from those olives.
I'm sure they sold it in various forms,
but one of the most popular
was for this purpose.
Everybody in the Mediterranean
wanted it for the same reasons.
And obviously there's these Mycenaean
sites had access to what they needed.
It looks like, by the way, that the gut,
much of the perfume from
areas outside of Greece,
some of the best of it came from a
North East Africa as a matter of effect.
Uh, th th you remember the queen of
Sheba from the Bible? I say that,
but I, I shutter to think how many of
you have read the Bible. But anyway,
um,
she was so rich as to attract the interest
of King Solomon because that's where
those wonderful, uh, find smelling things,
frankincense and myrrh and stuff like
that was available useful for this
purpose. So, um,
they had to import that to make their
goods as saleable as they wanted.
And so,
so you have trade with the Mediterranean
and most especially the eastern
Mediterranean because that's where
the older, more sophisticated,
more civilized cultures were.
And that's where wealth was to compare
it to what was out in the West.
And so that's the pattern of trade.
And what you see is a
kind of cultural unity.
First of all,
within the Mycenaean world itself,
it is evident that these
different Mycenaean towns
all through the Greek on both
sides
of the GNC, uh, we're in
touch with each other.
And one of the things that's interesting
about that is you can see a pottery
styles that you can hardly tell
whether they came from one end of the
Mediterranean or another if
they're of the Mycenaean variety.
Because it was a single culture.
I don't mean there were no
local variations, but there
was this general unity.
I'm going to contrast that with the
situation in Greece after the fall of the
Mycenaean world.
And I was going to say not just
in the Mycenaean towns themselves,
but over the entire sea and indeed across
the Mediterranean in the years of the
Mycenaean period,
roughly from 1600 to 1100 or so,
BC you are dealing with a
largely unified culture.
What does it, um, what did we talk about
the world like these days? What's the,
what's the cliche?
Globalized world?
It was a globalized world except there
was a little piece of the globe, but they,
they didn't really know or care about
very much outside of the Mediterranean
area.
Now in the respects that I have spelled
out and I mean chiefly the fact that
they were engaged in
commerce and industry to,
to some degree and that they were trading
peoples and that they were in touch
with one another and so
on. And, uh, they were, uh,
already similar to the civilizations
that came before them in the ancient
Mediterranean near east,
in those places in Egypt to Pharaoh in
Mesopotamia at first individual city
states were ruled in the
same way as everybody.
I'm going to be talking about
now by somebody who was a king,
a monarch,
a one man ruler who is the warlord,
the commander of the armies who has
the control of the power in the state.
But more than that,
all the economic activity that we find
in and our best example of what I'm about
to say is in Mesopotamia in the
cities of the Tigris Euphrates valley,
the ruler there from his palace assisted
by vast groups of bureaucrats directed
the economy of his land
entirely and fully.
Agriculture was
overwhelmingly the activity,
the most important activity of the
people of that area of anyway area.
And so, um, we have
evidence that the king,
uh,
doled out seed for planting instructed
people just exactly when to plant,
where to plant, what to plant
there, when to fertilize it.
If they did in Mesopotamia,
they usually didn't need to because
of the richness of the soil. Uh,
and so on.
In other words,
you have a degree of centralized control
of true monarchical power of a wealthy
monarchical power already
the model is there in Asia,
and again,
I keep,
I want to say it's the same but as
special way in Egypt because in Egypt,
the whole Nile Valley,
because I think of the nature of the
Nile Valley became totally centralized
under the rule of one man, the Pharaoh,
and he commanded the whole thing.
It took longer for anything like
that to happen in Mesopotamia,
although it ultimately did. When we
get, for instance, down to the 17,
about 1750 BC in Mesopotamia at Babylonia,
which is at that point,
the dominant kingdom of the area,
uh,
King Hammurabi has just about the
same power as a a pharaoh would in,
in Egypt.
It's also worth pointing out that these
rulers had full religious authority for
their rule. In the case of
the, the pharaohs of Egypt,
the Pharaoh was himself a god and
insisted on being worshiped in that way.
In Babylonia,
for instance.
And this I think was typical
Hammurabi was not a god,
but as we know, thank
God to uh, by the, uh,
the great steely that he left
that's now in the Louvre, the,
the law code of Hammurabi
is available to us.
And there's a,
a preface to it in which he basically
explains why should you obey the rules
that I am now aligning
a laying down for you.
And his answer is because the top God of
our World Marduk up pointed me in that
space and I'm doing
what he wants me to do.
And if you cross me, you cross
him. And that's bad news.
That's a rough translation.
Um,
so, um, this is very important.
You have a full monarchy in the sense
that both we and America talk about the
separation of church and state.
That is a very rare and unusual
thing in the history of the world.
The normal situation in cultures,
pre civilized and civilized as well,
is for there to be a unity between
religious things and a nonreligious things
and all of that to be ruled by a single
individual who is the monarch of that
territory with religious sanction as
well as through his power and through the
legitimacy of his dissent.
That's the normal human way of living.
You should always be aware,
I think of about how peculiar we are.
We are the odd balls and the history of
the human race and anybody who follows
our pattern.
And it's important to realize that
because there's nothing inevitable about,
uh, the development that has come about
to be characteristic of the world.
And when we find people challenging it,
I think they have the bulk of time and
human experience on their side when they
say, you guys got it wrong. So
let me say something about the,
the nature of the society and economy
that we find in the Mycenaean world
revealed both by the archaeology and by
what we learned in the records provided
by linear B, the remains in records
of these strongholds. Make it clear.
That's a political organization was
an imitation of oriental Monique,
the sovereignty of the sovereign
at my Sini rather, and a high loss.
Another important sites for
the period and at seeps,
which was another one was somebody
that the tablets referred to as the one
knocks and that is the same as a later
Greek word which drops the w at the
beginning on ox and as we shall see,
that word in later times means
some powerful individual,
but it doesn't mean what it means here.
The boss,
the single monarchical
controller of everything,
he held a royal domain that
belong directly to him,
which was very significant
in size and wealth.
He appointed bureaucratic officials,
he commanded royal servants
and he recorded royal goods,
which by the way,
most of the tablets are inventories
lists of things that exist in the palace
that belonged to the king.
There were others things that have to
do with instructions that the king is
sending out to people from the palace.
There was no reference
in any of the tablets.
I don't know how much we can make of that
because the tablet's limit themselves
to such a limited kind of thing that
maybe it doesn't prove anything.
But in this case, I think it does.
Uh, there is no reference to law.
There is no reference to some objective
or anything other than the king himself
in the administration of justice.
One scholar says it is natural
to infer that's a king.
All powerful controller of the all
seeing bureaucracy possessed supreme
authority also in the region of
lawmaking and law enforcement.
And I'm the president.
Bureaucracy with it's detailed and all
encompassing records gives the clearest
picture of the power exercised by the
centralized monarchs of the Mycenaean Age.
The records discovered at Pi loss
here are particularly interesting.
They cover only one part of a year and
yet they carry details of thousands of
transactions in hundreds of places.
These files,
as we might call them,
are both sweepingly inclusive
and penetratingly minute.
For instance,
bronze is allocated to different places
for the manufacturer of arrowheads or
sorts with a note telling how many smiths
in each place are active and how many
are not.
Cretin sheep are enumerated,
uh, to the amount of 20,000
and sorry, that's not right.
They don't want to get this wrong.
25,051 and we learned
that in a Cretin village,
two nurses,
one girl and one boy are employed.
We are told how much linen is
expected from a place called Rian.
What is the acreage of the
estate of a man called electron?
And what a guy named
Donius owes the palace.
The answer is 2100 liters of barley,
526 of olives for 68 of wine.
Hope you remembering all
this. 15 rams, one fat hog,
one cow and two bulls.
We even learned the names of two oxen
owned by [inaudible] glossy and Blackie.
The records make it perfectly clear
that the kingdom of pilots and Kinesis,
the kingdoms, we're bureaucratic
monarchies of a type unexpected in Greece,
but in many ways similar to some
contemporary and earlier kingdoms in the
eastern Mediterranean.
It is very unlike anything we associate
with the Greeks or anything that ever
again existed in the Greek world and
that's really the point I want to make
this.
Although these people are Greeks are
ruling a culture which is thoroughly
different from the one we will be
studying for the bulk of the semester.
So like the eastern states, you have
a powerful ruler who was a warlord.
There's a palace economy,
there is a script,
there is a bureaucracy and
there was collectivized
agriculture under the central
control of the economy.
That economy and that society
go forward and flourishes for,
as I say,
about 400 years,
maybe perhaps about 400 years and then
a bunch of terrible things obviously
begin to happen that shake the security
of this society and ultimately bring it
down.
Roughly speaking about 1200 BC,
we hear of general attacks that are
going on around the Mediterranean against
the various civilizations of which we
know Egypt experiences a number of attacks
from the outside world.
Chiefly,
what we hear about is from in the area
of the Nile Delta right there on the
Mediterranean Sea. Among those
attackers, there are others besides,
there are attackers from Libya.
We here,
but they're also attackers that
are simply called from the sea,
the sea people attacking at the roughly
the same time the dominant empire in
Asia Minor Anatolia is that run by a
people called the Hittites who have been
there for hundreds of years,
insecurity and are now suffering assault.
We know that because they also
have a writing which we can, uh,
read and it speaks of it as well as
the archaeological remains that show
destruction. Similarly
attacks are going on, uh,
against the kingdoms of
Syria and of Palestine,
which, uh, it can, I, you know,
it's always hard to know what that
piece of land should be called at any
particular moment,
but I call it Palestine because one of
the sea peoples at attack denial in the
round 1200 neat in Egypt, uh,
are called the Pellis set.
And most scholars suggested that is the
same name as came to be the name for
this region when they
ruled it called Palestine.
And you will remember that when
the Bible talks about this,
it refers to a people
called the Philistines.
These are thought to be all the
same people. So since they ruled it,
until uh, uh, what's his name,
Samson took them out with
the jawbone of an ass.
Ma, I think it's proper to it
Palestine at that moment. Um,
Cypress likewise suffers
from these attacks and so
far west as Italy and Sicily
are under,
something
is going on.
The question of course,
is what scholars have disagreed and
continue to disagree because the evidence
simply will not permit
any confident a answer.
But I ought to just mention a few of the
theories that have been tossed around a
few, among many, many, many,
one that seems to be in,
in fashion these days,
although you never know how long the
fashion lasts is a internal uprisings that
somehow these monarchical
areas when life got tough,
that people must have
risen up against them.
I think this reflects hopeful Marxists
wish fulfillment rather than any reality,
but it's not entire, well, that's not
what poor people have done in history.
If you look at revolutions,
revolutions come typically when things
are getting better and the people don't
like the fact that they don't
have more than they already have.
But in any case that that's one
theory, earlier theories, uh,
it's wonderful to have a scientific
theories that you can use to handle these
problems, which you cannot
demonstrate any facts for whatsoever.
I'm being a bit strong,
but not too much. Uh,
the one theory made some investigations
of earth spores hoping to find a,
what do you call that? Stuff that floats
around and makes you sneeze. Pollen. Yeah.
And, uh, um, behind that as a result,
they said there were droughts in these
areas throughout that period and that
caused tremendous
unhappiness and discontent,
deter other people have
suggested climatic shift.
I keep waiting for somebody that I think
the time is ripe for somebody to come
up with theory and explain
it by global warming. Also,
we know that the island in the middle
of the Aegean Sea called Theara,
uh,
blew up in the most enormous,
kind of an explosion at some point
back there in prehistoric days.
And one theory is it was the explosion
on Theara that caused so much climatic
trouble that, um, uh, it, it
can explain what went on here.
The trouble is you just don't know
when that explosion took place.
And since there are,
uh,
several periods in this general area
that we're talking about now in which
something big happen, some
great change takes place. Uh,
it turns out different people want to
have their explosion at different times.
It's like a movable feast.
You put your explosion where you
need it at any particular moment.
I am I making light of it
and I think it's, it's, it's
somewhat justified because,
uh, the evidence is
just so scanty. It just,
I think it's fun to play
the game these guys do,
but we shouldn't take it too seriously.
Now let's go back to a theory which has
at least got the virtue of being very
old, although hardly
anybody believes it anymore.
That is the theory that what
happened in the Mycenaean world,
let's forget what was happening elsewhere,
was the result of a movement of tribes,
of ethnic groups who were outside the
Mediterranean region and say at the
beginning of this period and say
in 1600 but who press into it.
Usually the picture is if they are coming
from the north of the North East and
pressing down into it,
I have to believe that whoever came up
with that theory for the first time was
aided and coming to it by thinking
about the end of the Roman empire when
something precisely like that did happen.
These Germanic and other tribes who were
largely located north and northeast of
Europe came down.
Uh,
or I should say not on Europe of the
Roman Empire came down and ultimately
destroyed it by invasion.
And even of course,
there are more theories about the fall
of the Roman Empire then there are about
the fall of the Mycenaean world.
But anyway,
behind connected to all of this was a,
a very interesting Greek myth,
which speaks about the return
of the Harris [inaudible].
They are the sons of the mythical hero,
Herrick Herrick Lees,
who was a Peloponnesian figure. And, uh,
the story goes that the
sons of [inaudible] were
expelled from the Peloponnesus
and then promised that they would come
back a hundred years later and conquer
it. And so they did come back a
hundred years later and conquer it.
And since this is the link that explains
the old story since in historical Greek
Times,
let us say the fifth century BC,
the people who inhabited the Peloponnesus
were mainly speakers of the Greek
dialect called dark.
It was thought that Harris, please, sons
and Harris please being Peloponnesians,
no doubt spoke dork too.
And so this was referred to as,
uh,
by scholars in the 19th century.
Not by the ancient Greeks
as a Dorian invasion.
In other words,
another kind of Greek,
the Greeks who lived in the area
before the fall of the Mycenaean world,
what would they call? Well, it
homework gives us several names
for them.
Three stick out for me.
The most common and the
most widely used was a kins.
Another one is Dan [inaudible]
and a third one is our jives.
Our drives comes from the fact that they
rule over the land of our gos in Greece.
Now,
the one that has some clout
historically is Akins because in the uh,
uh,
records of the Hittite kings,
there are references to people.
Uh, I'm trying to think. I think they
are called. I want to get this right,
but I don't remember what this is.
The Egyptian or the something like a high
wash off, unless that's
the Egyptian form. Anyway,
they are called by names.
That sounds something like that.
One among the Hittites
one among the Egyptians.
And it's so easy given the fact that,
uh,
the letter w dropped out of the Greek
language between the Mycenaean period and
the classical period.
You could easily imagine that
these people were referred to them,
refer to themselves as a high.
Why?
And when the Dow drops out, they are a
high oil, which is what homer calls them.
And so the idea here is that,
um,
the original Greeks who came
in were what we call a Akins.
And that when these disturbances came,
and if the Dorian theory is true,
Dorian's either kill them
all or dominated them,
possibly into married with them,
but dominated them and washed away,
wiped out the use of the akin language
and impose their own Dorian language upon
it and supporting such an idea among
other things is that if you go to the
mountains in the center of
the g of the Peloponnesus,
where it's awfully hard to get to,
there is a region called,
uh, well actually beyond those
mountains on the northern shore, uh,
is a place called a Kia
where the people are Akins.
And so the theory might be,
well,
they were driven away from their old homes
in the southern Peloponnesus and went
up to the northern Peloponnesus.
And then there are the people in the
mountains of our Katiya who also don't
speak to doric language. And, uh,
maybe they were driven up there to escape.
So those are the things that
help people decide that, uh,
to Dorian's May really have been the
peep to sons of [inaudible] who actually
invaded.
Uh,
and that what we find after the fall of
the Mycenaean world in Greece are some
of the following things,
things that were not typically found
in the Mycenaean world. First of all,
iron weapons,
not bronze ones.
A kind of a pin used to hold your cloak
together called a fibula unknown in the
previous period,
the building of buildings in the shape
of what the Greeks called a Mega Tron,
a rectangular center,
which has a hearth in it,
a front porch and a back porch,
which will be the style in which Greek
temples are built in the historical
period that appears for the first
time after the fall of the Mycenaeans.
We know that the Mycenaeans bury
their dead by inhumane option.
Those great tunes,
those great grave things,
and even the common people
outside them are buried in graves.
Whereas in a historical period,
these people were cremated
rather than buried,
uh, in, in the world of homer.
That's what we see. So the,
uh,
idea that was put forward in 19th century
was that the Dorians who worry less
civilized, tougher, meaner,
harder fighting people assisted by
the use of iron and in their weapons,
which is superior allegedly to the Browns,
uh,
came down,
defeated the Akins,
impose themselves on them where they could
drove them away, where they couldn't,
and that explains how things went that
has been attacked and is largely not
believed these days for a whole lot of
technical reasons that I don't want to
trouble you with right now.
I do not think we can believe
that simple story as it stands,
it is too simple and there are too many
things that it doesn't account for and
there are too many things that
would suggest that it's not correct.
However, I am not sure there
is nothing in that story.
And here. I really am influenced
most strongly by my colleague,
uh, Professor Jerome Pollack
now retired, uh, who was, uh,
our,
uh,
history of art and archeology guy who
has a notion that it's very nuanced and
sophisticated and it
appeals to me quite a lot.
He suggests that there were indeed Greek
tribes from the north who spoke Dorian
dialects who came down during this
period attempting to come into the,
uh,
richer and better settled world of the
Mycenaeans and they didn't come down and
then go be away for a hundred
years and then come back.
But rather they came down in waves of
tribes and families and so on exerting
gradual pressure, pushing in when they
could retreating when they couldn't.
Uh, and so on. And for this,
I think there's a very good it whether
or not you accept the dory and idea.
I think we need,
we should find attractive.
The idea that if there
was an external invasion,
it came in this way over a period of time,
a century or two with
success and then retreat,
not to having success flight,
all that kind of stuff going on.
Uh wait,
because the Mycenaean centers all reveal
for that stretch of time that they're
scared to,
proof of it comes from strengthening
their already quite strong walls in almost
all the sites that we see.
And also this is a very important fact
if you're expecting to be attacked and
besieged as all these citadels
would be by an invader,
you want more than anything else,
a water supply,
but they didn't necessarily have good
water supplies in such circumstances.
And so we see the building of
water holders in these places.
There's a very striking one.
The next time you go to my Sini,
don't miss the cistern that was dug
in the mountains and the hillside,
uh,
within the walls at that period.
It's deep and you better take a
flashlight because it's as black as it can
possibly be.
But they spent a lot of time,
energy and money on being
sure that they would have a,
a supply of water to hold
them for a long siege.
I think that indicates that
something of the kind is going on.
And then we see that when
this culture comes to an end,
it is accompanied by people fleeing,
getting away from the Mycenaean world.
Some of them go only so far is Athens,
which had the good fortune
somehow of not being destroyed.
One of the few important Mycenae
in places that is not destroyed.
So for some reason it was safe in
Athens and some fled to Athens.
Others had to keep going and settled
on the islands of the Aegean Sea.
For others it was necessary to go further
and to settle the west coast of Asia
Minor,
which indeed this is the great period of
Greek settlements on the west coast of
Asia Minor.
And then it looks like there came a
moment where there was a final blow where
whatever was attempting to overthrow
these cities and this civilization
succeeding not the same in every place.
The fall of Pi loss is generally
thought to be around 1200 BC.
My CD itself,
maybe 50 years later and uh,
other places later than that.
I think it's very important to notice
that some of these places that were big in
the Mycenaean world,
we're entirely abandoned and
not settled again by the Greeks.
Buried lost people didn't
even know where they were.
That's extraordinary.
That only happens when something very,
very large drives people
away from an inhabited site.
And so here's where,
uh,
Jerry Pollack's analogy to the fall
of Rome seems so very appealing.
That is more or less what did
happen in the Roman world.
And I don't see anything that suggested
it couldn't happen in the Greek world at
the time we're talking about,
I'm trying to figure out,
uh, we quit when tend to one. Right?
Right. Yeah. Okay. Um, now
I suppose the most important aspect of
all of this for our purposes are the
results of all of this.
And they were tremendous.
You have the destruction completely
of the Mycenaean Bronze Age culture.
Greece never sees anything like it.
Again,
this is not the way it was
in the ancient near east.
This is not the way it wasn't Egypt.
There you see continuity for a very,
very long time. The Greek world
has this tremendous discontinuity.
It's like the door slams and
you've got to go into a new room
among the things that
are lost for a long time.
There is writing,
there is no writing in Greece from,
let us say 1100 or so on
until the middle of the eighth
century BC rough date, seven 50.
And then the writing that they do have
is completely unrelated to the writing
that was lost. They get it from a
different place. The letters, the, this,
the design of the writing comes in fact
from Asia probably from almost certainly
from Phoenicia, the land that
is now called Lebanon. And uh,
the language that was for that
script wasn't Semitic language.
Hebrew is close to what's going on there,
but they don't take the language.
They borrow the characters from what had
been already something quite close to
an alphabet and had only
a relatively small number.
I forget the exact number of the
ones in the Semitic alphabet, but we,
you're talking about roughly 25. Do you
mean you're into the ball game for a,
uh, an alphabet such as
ours? The Greeks borrow that.
But typical Greek, uh, innovation,
they do the big step of inventing vowels
so that now you don't have to remember
anything.
You can read every sound that is made
and they produced their alphabet,
but their alphabet has got
nothing to do with my [inaudible].
This is a new thing altogether.
The Greeks are totally illiterate
from around 1100 to seven 50.
Another characteristic of these years
between which scholars refer to as dark
ages, just as they do the years
after the fall of the Roman empire.
Dark for two reasons.
Dark in the most obvious way
because we don't have any writing,
no record of them.
We can't see it's dark.
The other dark in the sense of gloomy,
not good,
bad. This is a hard time with a poor
time, retro time, miserable time.
These are dark times. So that's
what is meant by the term dark ages.
And that's what does follow the
fall of the Mycenaean world.
Part of the story is that
that old connection that
the Mycenaean world had with
the Mediterranean in general, most
particularly with the east, uh,
stops.
We don't find in the excavations we
make of Greek towns in the dark ages,
we don't find implements
a Jewel's goodies,
anything from Egypt and
Mesopotamia or anything like that.
It is clear and nor by the way do you
find Greek things in those places.
The Greeks are isolated
during this period. Of course,
everything I'm saying
is somewhat exaggerated.
I'm sure there must have been
individual exceptions to everything,
but we're talking about
the overwhelming reality.
And not only are the Greeks as a whole
cutoff from the rest of the world,
but Greece itself,
which used to be an area of easy exchange
where people could go from one place
to the other end.
Did localism now comes into the picture.
The unity is broken.
It's again like think I hope you know
something about the early Middle Ages
where places where simply cut off one
from the other and there were no roads
kept or made.
Uh,
and just going from one village to
another was a strange and dangerous thing
because nobody was in charge.
Things were completely out of control.
That's the way things, clearly we're
in the Greek world. For instance,
you can see pottery which
used to have this member,
this largely unitary quality.
You can tell if you're at all
experienced with it very easily. Uh,
if you'd go,
let's say to in a year 900 BC,
you can tell if a pot comes from Athens
or if it comes from Pi loss or pyloric
may probably out of business teams to
someplace else because they have their
local characteristics which
are perfectly obvious,
which suggests that they're
not seeing each other's goods.
They're not trading them.
They're simply working within
their own very narrow ambit.
That's the kind of a world
that is being created.
Something less easy to say confidently,
but probably clear I think is the whole
legacy of Mycenaean culture is really
lost.
Not fully though.
There is always something that we call
folk memory that has a recollection of
the distant past,
which may have truth to it but may not
or it may have only an element of truth
to it and it's always very hard.
What comes back in this form
is usually what we call legend.
And anybody who reject rejects legend
across the board as simply being invention
is just dead wrong.
Anybody who tries to use it as an accurate
account of what really happened is no
less wrong. Someplace in the middle is
where the truth is and it's hard to find.
But in any case,
what we find are a number
of units in the Greek world,
call them towns for the sake of argument.
It sounds too urban,
but call them that small.
That means to say smallest extent,
few people,
crystal population surely went down
since the capacity to grow food to
distributed that whole system,
that dependent on the existence of a
central palace and a strong king running
everything, running production, running
distribution, it's gone. And you know,
that doesn't come back when that's
destroyed, you're in terrible shape.
So the uh,
uh,
the population surely dropped and all
the evidence we have supports that.
So what you have are these small,
poor,
weak units and that's a miserable
situation and now they have no choice.
They cannot rely as human
beings typically do.
On just doing what your parents did.
Just inheriting a tradition
that functions, that works,
that keeps you going.
He couldn't do it.
The survivors had to figure out a new
way to do things and they didn't do
anything new in a hurry is all came hard.
And at the cost I'm sure have a lot
of human life and a lot of misery.
But what comes out of it is something
different. Now. I jumped though.
We do know that certain memories lasted.
They,
the Greeks always thought
there was an earlier age.
The Greeks of the classical period always
thought there was an earlier age that
was much better than the
age in which they lived.
An Age in which men were heroes.
They were bigger,
they were stronger, they were
tougher, they were faster,
they were more beautiful,
they lived longer.
Those were the great old days. And then
there's us, we pour miserable wretches.
That's the picture that the
Greeks carried with them. Uh,
the legends, just stories from
generation to generation, changed,
molded, but nonetheless retaining certain
elements of the earlier tradition.
And then finally we,
we have to believe that there's no it,
I think that there was another
thing that provided for memory,
something we call the epic tradition.
When we get to homer,
we will find a highly
developed epic poetry.
And once we come to grips
with the fact that it was, uh,
orally composed and recollected poetry,
then you'll get some idea of the length
of time that must have been involved in
the creating of it.
And once we'll turn to this,
when we get to the Homeric issues,
once you realize that there are clearly
accurate depictions of aspects of the
Mycenaean world that
show up in those poems,
which appeared to have been
written down for the first time,
perhaps around seven 50 BC or so,
then you must realize there had to be
an epic tradition of poetic tradition at
the same time that goes back all the way
to the metal, to the Mycenaean period.
And I think we must remember that there
were people creating and repeating and,
and working out and changing a poetic
tradition that started in the Mycenaean
world and lasted for the
rest of Greek history.
Now the legacy from the Mycenaeans to
Greek civilization later is very limited.
But what there is is very important and
no part of it is more important than the
Homeric poems themselves.
But if we look at the
society that emerges,
this dark age society that emerges
from the ancient world of my Sini,
what'd you have as a rare human
experience? The creation, all,
most of a clean slate,
even more so,
I would argue then the disruption
that it came after the fall of Rome,
because there's one big difference.
The fall of Rome did not destroy
one of the most important,
tenacious and significant
aspects of the old culture.
The Roman Catholic Church,
which remained and became a
central fact for the new culture.
There's nothing like that
in the Mycenaean world.
We are really talking about something
that's almost entirely fresh.
The Greeks had no choice but
to try to find their own way.
Uninfluenced as my Sini was influenced
by Mesopotamia and Egypt uninfluenced by
anything starting from the lowest possible
place and having to make a living and
to go forward and to shape
a world which was their own,
because there wasn't
anything else to guide them.
Next time we'll take a look at the
dark ages and the world of homer.